a thirteen-year-old boy is now charged
with felony murder in the death of a New
York City College student as a hunt
intensifies for a possible accomplice
the middle school student who is not
being named appeared in family court
yesterday police say that he was present
when Tessa majors was stabbed in a park
mola Lang he's at Barnard College where
majors was a freshman mullah good
morning to you what have you learned
about the search for a possible
accomplice in this case oh good morning
Gail yeah of course the 14 year old has
still not been located Monday night he
was allegedly being driven to speak with
police when he hopped out of a car and
took off on foot police scoured Upper
Manhattan yesterday looking for the 14
year old the same day the 13 year old
who implicated him was charged with
felony murder and first degree robbery
now the 13 year old allegedly told
police that he went to the park with two
friends to rob someone in court
yesterday an NYPD detective who
interrogated the boy said surveillance
video near the scene shows that he never
actually touched majors or ever held a
knife but the teen allegedly told the
detective that he picked up the knife
when the friend dropped it before the
robbery and that he was present when
Majors was killed the majors as we know
was found face down and not breathing
the 13 year old is charged as a juvenile
and if he is found guilty in New York he
can only be held at a juvenile facility
until he's 21 years old in a statement
the boy's attorney cautioned people not
to rush rush to judgment and that the
boy should be presumed innocent and of
course they also sent their condolences
out to Majors friends and family and as
you can see behind me here at Barnard
College a makeshift memorial has also
been set up to remember majors Tony I
think everyone involved in this case is
only a teenager molla thank you